thank you so much for joining us this
afternoon commissioner i just want to
tell everyone else
welcome and thank you for joining us for
today's important webinar
uh regarding the copen 19 vaccination
distribution plan
my name is alexander dazlis i'm the
director of government and public
relations for the nevada restaurant
association
joining us today is clark county
commissioner chair marilyn kirkpatrick
who has graciously agreed to come speak
to us today
on this webinar to share some
information with our restaurant
operators and affiliates
please keep in mind that after the
presentation we're going to be taking
time to answer your questions
so feel free to enter them into the chat
box and we'll get those
questions answered uh commissioner
kirkpatrick welcome and perhaps you want
to take over from here
yep no thank you and i'm going to try
and get to your questions right away
because i appreciate that you all were
waiting
and uh really uh i just kind of wanted
to tell you
what what our scenario is so that you
can understand
uh where we're at uh one there's 35 000
vaccinations that come to the state as a
whole
so we have to work through our process
um in a slow and methodical way because
the last thing that we want to do is
waste
um vaccines i can tell you to date we're
doing a really great job
in clark county and as a whole working
towards that a lot of people have asked
how was the plan put together that this
was a state rollout plan
based on some cdc guidance and based on
some things that they have to put
together
so um no good deed goes unpunished
trust me people have been blowing me up
how could i be so awful and i will tell
you this
i didn't make the plan however clark
county
itself has stepped in to help finance
the plan
so that we could have as many sites as
possible
so that when we get more vaccine we can
get them out quickly
some of the reason that the 70 and older
were picked
is because our hospitals today are full
of the 60 to 80
folks that are currently at our hospital
capacity
which is we want to make sure that
they're safe
so we are working on the 70 the cdc
guidelines says 75
um but the governor came out with a 70
um
or older plan and what i would tell you
there's about 208
000 seniors within that period because
we're such a great place to
retire so we're working many different
ways
we are still working believe it or not
through the medical
community we are still working through
our public safety community
and one of the reasons that the front
line piece was open specifically
is because i have my food banks i have
some social worker
social service workers i have some
juvenile justice spokes so we are trying
to
get some of those folks in what i will
tell you at cashman yesterday we did
well over 2
000 vaccines at western they
will do over a thousand today so
we are we're working hard to get as many
out as quickly as possible um next week
we should see cbs
walgreens and smiths i believe it is
able to start giving vaccinations
so they were the ones that have a
federal contract they were expected
to start the seniors first so we can
move through that other track
however they have not gotten their
direct allocation
from the federal government so at the
state level
we are sharing some of our allocation
with them to ensure that we can get to
those seniors
so that's a broad scope of what's going
on
um and we're all working around the
clock to
try and address things but i know that
you guys have some real questions so i
want to try and
for you of course um i think we have
one that was just submitted into our
chat box again everyone please
feel free to submit your your questions
there i know you guys are all muted so
that's your
that's your line of communication um our
first question is
uh why is food service not included in
the front line supply chain category
every other step in the food processing
chain from farm packaging to delivery
is above the actual person who handles
the food and serves it to the guest
how can you justify that so um i can
justify because that's not the county's
role
and i didn't create the i didn't create
the plan so
i don't know um and nor did the local
health authority
so the state has worked with the cdc
so i'm not sure what that reasoning is
for
except that maybe across the country um
agriculture in some places play a big
role we know
early on that we had a huge
problem with transportation and supply
chain that we couldn't get
products to different states around the
country
and so i have to assume that there were
some of those things that they seen from
the beginning
of kovid taking in but i'm happy to try
and get that specific
question answered from the states but um
we did not it wasn't done
we are just following the list um but i
got to believe that
the cdc and the state
who've been working very closely
together there must be a reasoning
behind it and i'll try and find that
reason for you great
uh we have another question it says you
created a separate vaccination site this
week for teachers only
why not next week set up a site that is
for hospital
hospitality only it would streamline the
process of getting these important
workers vaccinated quickly and
efficiently
so i'm going to go back to the 35 000
vaccines that we get every week for the
entire state
there are some remember that there are
some
folks some teachers around the school
that are actually in the classroom
that are teaching whether you're in
lincoln county you're in eureka county
humboldt county
washoe county many of our charter
schools and our private schools they
have
educators within the classroom
so i'm assuming that is why that was
done the reason that
we created a separate pod for
um education is because they were
bogging down the entire system for
everyone so
a couple of things we like to do
individual pods for
specific groups so make no mistake that
when hospitality we get to hospitality
we are
um you will see mega pods around the
valley just for
hospitality um because we have to be
flexible
on shifts we have to accommodate the
graveyard shifts the day shifts the
night shifts
and so that's always been within clark
county's plan and we will
we already have those uh many of those
sites lined out
many large facilities we've been asking
our congressional delegation
to please help us get more vaccines
because we all want to work
to a sense of normalcy
so that is why the separate pod was
created for
education is to get them out of the rest
because there are a lot of other folks
that we need to that are crucial to our
workforce that we want to ensure
that we can get to and you are many of
those folks that are crucial to our
workforce
great we also had some who were
submitting it
via email one of the questions is can
you explain further
how categories within the lanes may be
vaccinated
simultaneously
so i want to be mindful because i see
that the news is on here and you have
not
helped me as far as getting the message
out so i want to be very careful on how
i say this
because that's where half of our
confusion has come so no disrespect to
fox 5 or klas
but i just want to make sure that we get
the right information out
because on one hand um i have many folks
that are 78
and above that are very upset that they
cannot get the vaccine
and yeah on the other hand i have
crucial workforce that i need to ensure
that think that our community can still
run
in order to um provide services
and so um i hope that folks understand
that
70 and above are because they're the
most vulnerable within our community
today
and we want to get them because it helps
on many different levels
and as we're looking at the tracks we're
trying to have a little bit of
flexibility because the last thing that
we
ever want to do is have to throw away
vaccines and we
have not had to do that in nevada
although you're hearing about it across
the country we just need a little bit of
flexibility so that our vaccines do not
go to waste
we cherish each one of those vaccines
that come there are very
specific rules on how you can handle
each vaccine
so whether the pfizer which has to stay
at a certain temperature
and you get five to seven doses for
every vial what i wouldn't want to do
is to open a vial with one person
standing there because i would want all
seven of them to be used to the moderna
which
is um can be at room temperature
but that's anywhere between nine to 11
doses and i want to make sure that i
have those
many people in place at the time but we
also have to be equitable
across the community to ensure that we
we are getting that job done and that is
what we are trying very hard to do
and we are hopeful that the federal
direct allocation will come
soon which will allow us to move quicker
but
know that we have lots of different um
locations set up so in the event that we
get more vaccines that we can
bring it in and honestly i'm super
thankful for our national guard
it takes about 90 people to run a mega
site
and and at cashman we're doing
2 000 a day i don't know too many sites
that are doing less than a thousand a
day
but if you do the math for the long term
that means it's going to take us a
little while to get through there so
we're trying to get through as
many as possible as soon as we can
great we've received another one it says
have you considered developing a standby
option that would allow
eligible workers to get vaccinated early
if the location finds they have leftover
vaccines
so we haven't had that issue um yet and
we do
um we have many i have lists of senior
citizens yesterday we had about 20
spots open within a couple of hours
and um so i had a list of some seniors
from some of our senior communities we
were calling through to see if people
could get there but
what we are really not do and we take a
super good inventory about three o'clock
in the afternoon
to make sure so um
but i'll keep that in mind and see if
there's a list that we can create
um but most importantly i specifically
asked everybody to
fill out that survey because that helps
us manage
exactly how many people are interested
in getting the vaccine
so that we can move through that process
great we have another one in the chat
box that says um
how quickly will the county be able to
get their goal of 400
or for 440 000 vaccinations a week
we'll be able to meet our goal as soon
as we get that many vaccines
so right now we're waiting on that many
vaccines a week
what percentage of teachers need to be
vaccinated before we can move to
on to other categories i don't have that
answer the only reason that i am uh
you know look i feel that just by being
honest with folks and trying to answer
so many questions because everything
gets distorted
is why i'm doing that i'm a health board
member so i'm super engaged
in this process the health district is
the lead agency
but my role is the vice chair of the
health district and the chair of the
county commission
we have a great collaboration in
southern nevada as a whole
so we are all working together and i
just wanted to take an opportunity
to kind of tell you because a lot of
folks are frustrated on
many different levels and um look i
don't let anybody jump the line that's
not supposed to
my own husband's 68 and i'm like you're
not 70 so you're not going
i've not jumped the line so um
it's just we're trying to make sure that
we get a stable workforce
as well is our most vulnerable
vaccinated at the
that time we were on a national call
with our delegation and we hope
in february that we'll get tons and tons
more vaccinations
i can vaccinate just give me as many as
you got is my
been my answer to them
understood great um we just received
another one
do you have any insight into why the
governor places food service workers so
low
on the list compared to other states in
the western us
i don't and here's what i would tell you
i'm not here to monday morning
quarterback anybody this is a whole new
um thing that we've all been through i
wish i had time to stop and read what
other states are doing right now
um and i don't even know what their
vaccine allocation
is so there could be many reasons
and we are working closely with the
state so
um i'm not here to to
say that understood okay great um
any other questions uh please feel free
you guys there's the chat box on the
right hand side
um for any questions that we have
just give it a minute and i wanted to
say this
first of all i want to thank our
community because many of our medical
staff
have stepped up they're working
tirelessly to
not only through covet but now the
vaccine
vaccination process but we really have a
great community and
we we all want to get some sense of
normalcy
and get back on track um i would love
nothing more than to be able to go sit
at your restaurant uh at 100
capacity and actually have to wait
outside to get in
and there is a light at the end of the
tunnel we're moving towards that so
patience um it's got to go forward we're
working on some additional resources
but vaccines are our top priorities so
if you talk to anybody in
our national level ask them when can we
get more vaccines because we're ready to
go
great um i think we have
another one from in the chat box that
says um are resorts
talking with each county about how to
vaccinate the thousands of strip
and casino employees so we've always had
a plan for that so
we um resorts are large facilities
but until we can get some vaccinations
there's not much more that we can do
at this point because we are utilizing
every vaccine that we have
great another question is are the plans
to move restaurants further up if
more vaccines come through
here's what i would tell you i have to
work through the whole list
today um is what i'm seeing but if we
have
more vaccines available we'll be able to
go quicker through that list
so um i don't want to give anybody any
false hopes i don't know that
um you know uh restaurant
i i don't want we're all equal in this
right we're all needed in order to keep
our community going and to recover
so the more that we get um
the sooner that we can all get back to
normal
great we received another one from susie
it says how will we know when it's
available for the hospital for
the hospitality industry and is there
going to be a hierarchy within the group
so um what i would tell you is i've
asked everybody to fill out that survey
so that we could manage
what the number is for vaccines
and so when you and we'll keep the list
and
hopefully um by the time we get to
hospitality there's not
a lot of other groups out there um with
the exception of
maybe the 16 to 69
that we will be able to go through it
just like we have with any other tier
so i don't have an answer and here's
what i would tell you is
equalness right hospitality is the
backbone of
our community and we need everybody to
have the option to get it but what i
would also say is
only about 70 of the people across the
valley
are interested in giving it so filling
out those
uh guesstimates of what you would like
how many you think
would do it might give us an opportunity
to have a better idea of how many in the
hospitality
realm would want it great
we have another one from sarah she says
is there anything restaurants can do to
prepare to get
staff vaccinated more quickly when
supply is available
um yep it's that survey that i sent out
because that really does help us manage
uh how many folks
that we need alexandria has that survey
for you
and it really is just asking your
employees how many are interested
in getting the vaccine when it becomes
available and i say when it becomes
available because
it doesn't mean it's going to happen
tomorrow and
you know in some states they could be
going well through october
to uh to actually handing out the
vaccine and we could see ourselves
depending on how fast we get the vaccine
and going through june
before most general public would open it
so
we don't have a timing except that we're
working as
fast and we have built the capacity so
we are ready when we get more vaccines
great and i know we've been working on
that survey together so i'll be sure to
send that around to everybody in the
group
um following this webinar so that's the
answer to joe's question about where we
would need to find the survey for those
interested we have one other question uh
will restaurants that push their
employees to vaccinate be given priority
um oh i i don't know that um
i well i don't have the answer for that
i i don't i can't see that
being i we need to we open hospitality
we open hospitality that's a lot of
different people within hospitality
whether you have two employees or 2 000
employees
we recognize that so i don't um
the line is still the same right it was
like testing it's like vaccinations
still got to stand in that line um by
then you know we should have a new
computer system
uh in the next three about three weeks
that will help register even faster
so it will make us way more efficient so
our our goal is to get as many people
vaccinated as
wanted and as soon as we can
wonderful okay uh any further questions
i know you've answered a lot no i'd
rather just have a regular dialogue so
that you can
hear it from me if facebook could go
away for a week my life would be
so much better uh so
but i'd rather just have a regular
dialogue with you all so that we can
we did this with reopening when we
reopened we back in
may so we'd like to just continue a
dialogue so that we can help you be
successful and help us all get back to
normal
definitely thank you so much for your
time today commissioner
i know in our discussions you've
continued to tell me that you've been a
friend to restaurants you truly have
you've worked in the industry you
understand it
inside and out so when commissioner
kirkpatrick really does talk from a
place of empathy she really does
understand
what restaurant employers employees have
to kind of go through
the struggles that kind of surround that
so we really do appreciate
your time today and thank you so much
for answering our questions i'll be sure
again to send out the survey to
everybody
so that you can answer that accordingly
and hopefully we can continue to
log and have kind of regular check-ins
if possible
nope that would that would be great and
like i said we worked with you all when
we opened uh and i would bet that as we
open up further that we're going to want
to
um get rid of some of the restrictions
that are out there
so that is where um you know at some
point you guys will be helpful what's
the
most daunting restriction that you have
i can tell you for me what it is
self-service drinks we should like come
back
we've been trying since october but
that's where you'll be
important to know specifically what kind
of things
can help that are um really
um you know taking a toll on the extra
work i was a waitress
22 years so some of my best years were
making sure that
that was way back when a long time ago
when
creamers were not non-dairy and you had
to
keep them on ice the health district
thought you could keep them on
ice in a bowl on the table and that
sounded great but didn't really work
but i was in the food distribution where
you know we they were going to shut down
chocolate machines because they didn't
have the nsf on them
at some point i'm like but chocolate
never stops turning
so that's why i sit on the health
district because i understand
the realities of how we all have to work
to be
safe and to move forward so
anytime alexandria i do have to get to
something else so
um thanks and i'm always available
um to answer this and then there is a
website
there is an email where you turn the
survey back into
so that we can ensure that there's
a hard copy um for um each one of our
stations will have a hard copy
as well as um we'll have something for
the future
in the event that we need it wonderful
thank you again so much
and thank you everybody for tuning in
thank you